[Music]
[Applause]
[Music] [Applause]
i consider my teammate's family
and i
can say that the entire lockheed martin
team is honored by this special guest
today
it is a great honor
to introduce to you the president of the
united states
[Applause]
i tell you what linda
fire ceo of this company i'd be worried
well
good afternoon everybody and thank you
jim for the invitation to be here today
and linda for the warm welcome today
and congressman sewell woman soul thank
you for
all you do for the people of the state
in the country and for your friendship
our friendship
i want to come down to alabama to make
sure that the american people
know
what workers this food and by the way
you have a seat please take it
by the way sometimes the press is always
fair with me
but once every once in a while i make a
mistake
not like what once a a speech but anyway
i
years ago when i first started talking
to this
for this job
i said please take your seats
there weren't any seats everyone was
standing or no chairs
so i just want to make sure i checked
when you had seats
look
the american people
know what workers this facility are
doing and
support to support ukraine's fight for
freedom
and the bottom line is i came to say
thank you
thank you thank you
that's the reason i'm here
i've been in those battlefields where uh
these missiles are fired
and uh
i spent a lot of time going in and out
of iraq and afghanistan maybe a total of
40 times and uh i tell you what
you're uh i and i've been in ukraine a
lot prior to the war
and on the border since the war
and it's it's amazing what you've done
we see on the news every single day the
atrocities and the war crimes that are
being committed
by russian forces in ukraine directed by
vladimir putin
and it really is gut-wrenching
we see the incredible bravery the
ukrainian fighters defending their
country from with everything they have
and by the way it's not just their
warriors it's not just their military
it's people on the street
people on the street staying behind
a lot have gotten out of 5 million but a
lot are staying
including women
as well as men
stand to fight for their country
and and we know that the united states
is leading our allies and partners
around the world to make sure the
courageous ukrainians who are fighting
for the future of the nation have the
weapons and the capacity and ammunition
and equipment
to defend themselves against putin's
brutal war
a lot of war crimes being committed
but we don't what we don't see
we don't always see is the work
that's so much of that makes so much of
this possible
and that's you
it's not hyperbole it's you
you make it possible you make it
possible for them to have a shot you
know
during world war ii
the united states is known as the
arsenal democracy
there was rosie the riveter who actually
got to meet quite frankly before she
passed away
and a lot of people who in fact
kept the uh kept it going
i was a slight digression i went over
for the 50th anniversary
of
the uh
the end of world war ii
and uh
and i was in normandy and i went up
afterwards
i burst
and all of a sudden i heard behind me it
changed up
and i turned around and there was a
gentleman who had to be
in his early 80s in a wheelchair
being wheeled by his son who big guy
looked like hoss cartwright
and his and his wife
and one other and a daughter
and he saluted me so i saluted him
and at the time and the attorney i said
thank you for what you did
thank you for saving literally saving
civilization
and he put his hand
on his wife's his wife his hand was on
his shoulder and he said no no
she didn't
she did
i looked at her and said she built the
landing craft that got us in here
she
and her friends they're the ones that
did it and he went on
and he filled up and all of a sudden it
dawned on me
you're doing it
you really are doing it
you're making a gigantic difference for
these poor sons of guns who are under
such enormous enormous pressure and fire
power
those javelins i saw there's 10 for
every tank
that there is in ukraine right now
you're changing people's lives we built
the weapons now you really do
[Applause]
but we built the weapons and equipment
that helped defend freedom and
sovereignty in europe years ago
but that's true again today
you know some of the best most effective
weapons in our arsenal those javelin
missiles like the ones manufactured
right here in pike county
they're highly portable they're
extremely effective
against a wide range of armored targets
they can hit targets up to 400 meters
away
and have a fire and forget capability
that means the person firing can i know
you know it's for anybody maybe listen
can change positions or take cover
before that javelin even strikes home
target
in fact they've been so important
there's even a story about ukrainian
parents naming their children not a joke
their newborn child
javelin or javelina
not a joke
so the brave people of ukraine
including the many civilians who have
taken up arms to defend their country
deserve
every ounce of credit for pushing back
the russian assault and frustrating
putin's desire to dominate ukraine
we're at an inflection point in history
for real it comes along about every six
or eight generations
where things are changing so rapidly
that we have to be in control
folks there's an ongoing battle
in the world between autocracy and
democracy
xi jinping the leader of china who i've
talked about spent more time with than
any other world leader has
over 78 hours on either in person or on
the telephone with him
and the fact of the matter is he just is
straightforward about it
he says that democracies cannot be
sustained in the 21st century
not a joke
they cannot be sustained because things
are moving so rapidly
democracy require consensus and it's
hard to get consensus therefore
they can't keep up with an autocracy
one-man rule
but that's not going to be the case if
that happens the whole world changes
i mean because of you
in this first really battle if you will
for that to determine whether that's
going to happen
is because you're making it possible
you're making it possible for the
ukrainian people to defend themselves
without us having to risk getting a
third world war by sending in american
soldiers fighting russian soldiers
my dad used to have an expression he
said the only war worse than one that's
intended is one that's unintended
you're allowing the ukrainians to defend
themselves
and quite frankly they're making fools
of the russian military in many
instances
a big part of the reason they've been
able to keep up fighting
and to make this war a strategic failure
for russia is because the united states
together our allies and partners have
had their back
the united states alone has committed
more than 5 500 javelins to ukraine
you're changing the nation you really
are
add to that significant supplies from
our allies and partners as well as many
thousands of other anti-tank and
anti-air weapons helicopters armored
vehicles artillery coastal defense
systems
before russia attacked
we made sure russia had javelins and
other weapons to strengthen the defenses
so ukraine was ready for whatever
happened
in the last two months we continued to
move even more resources and equipment
at a rapid pace in the ukraine
we've made sure that there are no
interruptions in the flow of equipment
to ukraine
since russia invaded ukraine just over
two months ago we have sent more than
three billion dollars
in security assistance to ukraine
alone us not counting our allies
and that money is a direct investment in
defending freedom and democracy itself
because if you don't stand up to
dictators
history has shown us they keep coming
they keep coming
their appetite for power continues to
grow
and every worker in this facility
and every american taxpayer is directly
contributing to the case for freedom
and that's something we can all be
incredibly proud of in my view
last week
i sent congress if you excuse a point of
personal privilege talking like an old
senator
but sent a supplemental budget a fancy
way of saying we need more money
to make sure the united states can
continue to send weapons directly to the
front lines of freedom in ukraine
and to continue to provide economic and
humanitarian assistance to help the
ukrainian people
and i urge the congress to pass this
funding quickly to help ukraine continue
to succeed against russian aggression
just as they did when they won the
battle of kiev
and to make sure the united states and
our allies can replenish our own stocks
of weapons
to replace what we've sent to ukraine
as i said from the beginning
this fight is not going to be cheap
but caving to aggression would even be
more costly
we either back the ukrainian people as
they defend their country or we stand by
as russia continues as atrocities and
aggression
i know what the answer is and i think
you all do too
i bet i know what the answer to this
plan is
there's something else here that to be
understood
being the arsenal of democracy
also means good paying jobs for american
workers
in alabama and the states all across
america where defense equipment is
manufactured and assembled
265 people here at this plant
are directly employed working on the
javelin program
all told lockheed martin has brought
nearly 3 000 jobs to alabama
the armed forces of the united states of
america will continue to be the best
armed most capable fighting force in the
history of the world
in order to do that
we have to make sure our vital defense
supplies are getting the inputs and
supplies they need to produce and
protect and provide the full capacity
i learned on the tour today
that each of the javelins you produce
includes more than 200 semiconductors
i've been a broken record as a
professional telly on our need to be
able to produce more semiconductors in
the united states
we invented the sucker going to the moon
we the united states
we're the one that modernize it we've
done more than anybody else
but guess what
we stopped investing in ourselves
we stopped investing on ourselves
and so now we're what back in the game
making sure that we become we become the
primary producer of those semiconductors
computer chips that power much of our
modern lives
on our phones our cars almost anything
that has an on off switch
and the semiconductor is critical to
defense production capacity as you know
you all know better than i do
that's why we're making it as hard as we
can for russia to get hold of these
semiconductors and advanced technologies
that it could use to upgrade its
military during this conflict
and why we're taking steps to make it
easier
to source what we need here in the
united states during the global
semiconductor shortage
and just one more there's just one more
reason why congress has to act quickly
to provide the emergency funding of the
so-called chips act
by passing a broader bipartisan
innovation act so we can produce tens of
millions of these chips
there's something we have to focus on
and something i focused on from my early
stages of our administration
i'm determined to make sure the united
states holds its technological high
ground
in competition with other nations
especially china as we move forward
folks you know uh we
we used to invest as a nation
years ago 35 years ago we invested
2 of our entire gdp in research and
development
we do half of that now
we do half of that we used to be number
one in the world
now we're number 13 in the world
my administration we're changing that
the united states used to own the
innovation field
in fact it was a department of research
program that established darpa
the first development of an anti-tank
missile with advanced infrared guidance
systems that culminate in today's
javelin
the bipartisan innovation act
is going to help reverse decades-long
decline in federal research and
development and investment
and it should create and support entire
families
and expand u.s manufacturing and
strengthen our national security wearing
god's name is written that the united
states can no longer be a leading
manufacturer in the world
we've created just in the last 17 months
465
000 permanent manufacturing jobs in
america
we have the best workers the most
competent employees the best science in
the world
and by funding the chipset we're going
to ensure that semiconductors the power
of the economy and our national security
are made here in america again
today
all
all the world's most advanced ships are
made overseas
but the events of the past few years
have proven beyond a doubt that
america's security should never be held
hostage to events overseas
not a pandemic not a war
not the politics of ambition
or other countries
fundamentally there's a nationalist a
national security issue
this is one of the reasons why the
chinese communist party is lobbying
folks
to oppose this bill
and it's an issue that unites democrats
and republicans
so let's get it done let's get it done
in an introduction
linda said she personally touched every
single solitary
javelin 50 000 that manufactured this
plant 20 years ago
i was worried to shake your hand i
thought you may or may not be elected
that's where they start
right here
with american skill
american craftsmanship
american patriotism
and just a few days ago the wall street
journal quoted a young hungarian fighter
saying and i quote without the javelins
would have been very hard to stop the
enemy pushing ahead end of quote
so these weapons touched by the hands
your hands
are in the hands of ukrainian heroes
making a significant difference
that's something each and every day you
could and should be proud of
i'm once more urging congress to quickly
pass this supplemental funding bill
over 300 billion dollars to help the
ukrainians so they can keep
they can keep all of the very very
all of you very very busy for a while
here
so again let me end where i began
i came from basic reason bottom my heart
to say thank you
thank you thank you thank you what you
do
thank you what you continue to do
unless you go out in the field and see
it you don't realize what a difference
you're making
may god bless you all
and may god protect our troops thank you
so much
[Music]
uh
[Music]
um
[Music]
oh